الان ينضم الينا من الكلاكله جنوبيه
الخرطوم مراسلنا محمد الطيب محمد كيف
تاثرت هذه المنطقه
بالقتال
وارصد لنا المواقع المدنيه التي تعرضت
للقسوه طارتها المعارك
نعم وسيله نحن الان في المناطق الجنوبيه
الغربيه من الخرطوم العاصمه وبالتهديد في
منطقه الكلاكله القبه عموما هذه المناطق
هي بعيده من العمليات العسكريه نوعا ما
وليست فيها عمليات متاخمه
في هذه المنطقه لكن لكنها تعرضت للقصد
تلاحظون الان خلفي هذه واحد من المنازل
التي تدمرت
بالكامل بفعل القصف هذه البيوت اغلب هذه
المناطق البيوت التي فيها هي بيوت شعبيه
وليست فيها نوعيه الخرسانه التي تبنى بها
البيوت الحديثه يعني نوعيه البيوت تبنى من
الطوب ومن الطين كما تلاحظون حتى ان سقفها
وسقف بسيط وليس من الخرسانه
والاسمنت وهذه البيوت تعرضت لقصف هذا
المنزل تعرض اهله للق عدد منهم كما عرفنا
من اهل المنطقه انهم الان يتداون يتداوون
ويستشفون في المستشفى القريب هنا في هذه
المنطقه نوعا ما الحركه والمستشفيات جزء
من المستشفيات يعمل
حسب ما عرفنا ان هناك ثلاثه عشر منزلا
تعرض
للقصف او انه تضرر بفعل القصف في هذه
المنطقه نتيجه الاشتباكات الدائره ما بين
قوات الدعم السريع وما بين الجيش السوداني
الاحياء هنا ما زال الهلع يسيطر على سكان
هذه المنطقه الذين التقينا بهم نلاحظ في
الشاشه الان ان عدد من سكان هذه المنطقه
يتضافرون في الجهود لترميم اثار القذف
التي لحقت بسوري منزلهم يعملون في محاوله
اعاده البناء لهذا السوره التي تطرف القصف
من الناحيه الاخرى هذا هذا المنزل نزل
برمته على العدو سوي بالارض بسبب الخاص
لان هذه طبيعه البيوت الموجوده في هذه
المنطقه هي بيوت سكنيه شعبيه
بسيطه
وليست فيها
الخرسانه او
الاسمنت وانها تبنى بطرق الحديثه نحاول ان
ندخل هذا المنزل الذي تضرر جزئيا بسبب
القصف في هذه المنطقه ونلتقي باهله لنعرف
ما الذي جرى بالنسبه لهم هذا هو رب هذه
الاسره
تعرض ما زالت الامور بالنسبه له هو يعني
هناك اثار ومتضرر يعني هل لنا هل صحتك
جيده
في بعض ما زالت يعني هناك اثار القصف
والاجزاء والجروح التي مازلت تتداوى بها
يعني ما الذي جرى لك والله نحن ضربت في
البيت باعتبار في البيت نحن جوا البيت
وقمنا
على الغزيف والحاجات دي جرير فلما خشينا
لجوه مع فطار الحته الباب قافل يلا باقي
الحديد والحاجات دي كلها دقت فينا يعني
مازلت انت يعني مصاب كيف تداويت مشيت
التركي من التركي تعني رجعت المنوره من
المنوره حتى نزعافات اوليه لازول باعتباره
تعلم
هل عانيت في قصه التداوي بالنسبه
لاثار الجروح التي اصيبت بها هاي لسه لسه
بجيب دواء هسه برضه من الزخانه من حاجات
بشكل واجيب حاجه ما في علاج في باعتباره
زعافات اوليه
عموما المنزل
يعني تضرر ضررا بليغا هذا المنزل
السقف هذا المنزل من الداخل تعرض للنزول
بسبب قوه الانفجارات التي تمت الزجاج في
هذا المنزل ايضا
تكسر كليه
وما زال الناس يعانون من هذه المشكله
ويحاولون الخروج هذا البيت اصبح غير صالح
للعيش تماما
التصدعات في الجدران تبدو واضحه
نزول السقف من مناطق مختلفه
بسبب
الضربه بسبب الدانه التي سقطت عليهما
والمتفجره الذي سقط عليه نتيجه هذه
المعارك هو الضرر كليا الان هم يفكرون
بالخروج من هذه من هذا المنزل اصبح غير
صالحه للعيش ويعدون العده
للخروج نتعرف ايضا على اهل المنطقه الذين
هم في هذه المنطقه يعني بالنسبه للسكان
الذي تضررت منازلهم بماذا يفكرون وبماذا
يخططون والله طبعا هما الناس ما عندها
حاجه تعملها
في هذه البيوت بهذه الشاكله ام انكم
تخططون لترميمها او للخروج منها والله
طبعا ما عندنا حاجه نقدر نعمل نقدر نعمرها
وربنا يسهل علينا يا رب العالمين يا الله
احنا قاعدين فيها مع ربنا
نتمنى ربنا سبحان الله يعيننا يا رب
العالمين الله يوفقنا يا رب
هذه هي وسيله يعني يعني ما تعرض له سكان
هذا الحي في منطقه الكلاكله القبه
ويحاول سكان التعايش مع هذه الاوضاع التي
يعتبرونها اوضاعا يعني مريعه وتصيبهم
بالذعر حيث ان هذه المناطق هي بعيده من
الاشتباكات لكن عدد من
القصف قالها ووصلها عموما
وما تزال وما يزال السكان يحاولون لملمه
بقايا منزلهم الذي
منازلهم التي تضررت 13 منزلا بحسب ما تحدث
لنا سكان تعرضت للقصف
وتعرضت لهذه الضربات
المختلفه
وبالتالي
الوضع يعني لاحظنا في هذه المنطقه هذه
المنطقه ربما
تحدد الشكل الانفجار الذي اصيبت به هذه
الحفره
الناجمه عن شده الانفجار في هذه المنطقه
تحدد حجم وقوه المتفجر الذي اصاب هذه
المنطقه وسيله الذعر التمسناه من سكان هذه
المنطقه يقولون انهم ليس لهم علاقه بما
يجري وما يحصل ويتمنون ان تتوقف هذه الحرب
السريعا حتى يعيش المواطنون باطمئنان
وامان وسلام نعم وسيله فعلا الوضع صعب
للغايه وهو بالتاكيد ينسحب على مناطق
عديده اتضررت من هذه المعارك في السودان
اشكرك جزيل الشكر مراسلنا محمد الطيب نقلت
لنا الوضع كيف يبدو من الكلاكله جنوبي
الخرطوم